parler de cette cérémonie exceptionnelle
avec notre invité michel cofondateur de
pignons international michel que bonjour
merci d'être en direct sur rt france
voilà quatre pays invités 1 sont à son
talonneur l'allemagne l'autriche le
luxembourg et la suisse
c'est une façon de les remercier pour
leur aide pendant la console terre
effectivement parce que deux français
roux était prêtre catholique frappé
l'impact ivic trop long et bruce et
comme malheureusement groupe victime
était dans l'est de la france
les journaux je suis moi même originaire
dans le lot 1 il y avait un moment donné
c'est vraiment saturation des hôpitaux
de mulhouse et de colmar vidéo commune
elle aux alentours et l'allemagne la
suisse l'autriche a loupé son groupe
aura cuisse afin d'aider les malades et
non au sol sur la vidéo effectivement
puisque bloc le présent à albi à sur la
pression de l'opinion 6 et a décidé
d'élargir un petit peu le thème du 14
juillet à aux victimes du coronavirus et
à celles et ceux qui me protéger les
français en cette crise il était de bon
ton de le saluer ses pipes goûter
solidaire plus fort de la crise alors
que le défilé traditionnel deviez 14
juillet
chaque année attendu par des millions de
français des milliers de personnes
d'ailleurs assiste en direct cet
événement avec voilà
le défilé sur les champs-elysées ce que
vous comprenez un peu cette frustration
de certains français qui voient là cette
année
regarde ce défilé un petit peu restreint
place de la concorde
egouttez-les non moi je suis pas
tellement d'accord parce qu'en fait je
trouve pour transporter le mal mais les
images de ce défilé entre guillemets je
trouve que ça renouvelle en fait
d'exercice on voit paris autrement on le
voit d'un autre point de vue
d'ailleurs on dit que paris est la plus
belle ville du monde je sais pas si
c'est vrai c'est bien prétentieux le
dire mais c'est quand même très belle
ville et on le voit sur les images pour
diffuser non je pense que justement
cette crise est peut-être l'occasion de
réinventer de revisiter nos symboles
nous les traditions de nos symboles et
je trouve que finalement c'est pas mal
que que cela change un petit peu ce soit
pas tous les ans les mêmes images
d'envoi aux tourments l'armée française
on voit également des soignants lindy
capaci d'ailleurs avait-il dit que les
premiers curbed et notamment les
soignants les médecins premières
dépouilles des pompiers tous les autres
très présent je ne les vois pas assez et
je trouve que ça renouvelle un petit peu
l'exercice
il pose pour tout vous dire dans mon
magazine principal au nez très attaché à
faire vivre les symboles mais aussi à
les renouveler la façon dont on les
transmet on a par exemple lancé hier
avec des bons sportifs on sait
l'initiative une minute de sueur pour la
france où ça lui est justement de
premier plan des je vous invite à lire
sur notre site internet
opinion internationale mais très
concrètement je pense que les images que
l'on voit en ce moment même sur une
manière vous renouveler cet exercice
commémorative cet exercice ne perdirent
les valeurs de la nation et honnêtement
moi je trouve cela le bien de loin les
choses autrement et et sam et sa mère
peu de nouveautés alors justement cette
édition 2020 et est inédite
voilà pas de public 2500 personnes ont
été conviées par 1400 soignants mais
aussi des professions qui ont été en
première ligne voir en 2d binh durant
cette crise sanitaire
est-ce que c'était important ce geste
symbolique de rendre hommage à toutes
ces personnes qui ont fait face à ce
prix sanitaires alors oui bien entendu
j'avais lancé un appel sur mon magazine
pour que les premiers cordes et c'est à
dire les soignants mais aussi les
magazines et les dockers les
transporteurs les caissiers dans les
magasins tous ceux qui ont fait vivre le
pays au plus fort du confinement
défilent en tête sur les champs elysées
ou place de la concorde
et c'est vrai que beaucoup ont été
invités ils sont sur la place de la
concorde
ob certains des films notamment des
soignants mais de l'armée française
moi je trouve que leur équipe de maille
options que en fait en tête de ceux de
ce2 ce défi lié on voit des de faire le
tour de la place de la concorde des
milliers de soignants et des milliers de
2 encore une fois de tous ces corps de
métier qui a su eux qui assurent la
manutention qu'il faut tourner la
machine france et sans lesquels nous
pourrions pas nous ne pourrions pas
vivre tout simplement
donc effectivement il ya une bonne
intention au niveau de la réalisation ça
reste quand même un événement surtout
militaire je pense pour ma part que nous
avons deux armées en france on à l'armée
française et l'armée des militaires
[Musique]
les forces de sécurité et qui est
indispensable à la sécurité de notre
pays et qu'il faut saluer comme on le
fait tous les 14 juillet ils vont plus
un rôle déterminant pour notre pays
notamment dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme et dans des théâtres
d'opérations extérieures plus de 550
français sont morts en cas d'opérations
extérieures depuis 1963 donc il faut les
saluer mais on a une deuxième armée
française qui est celle des soignants de
tous les l'ailé les cordes de la société
qui font vivre la société les
manutentionnaires les transporteurs les
éboueurs les dockers ils sont des
milliers des dizaines que des
humiliations des centaines de milliers
et c'est eux aussi dans la marine
française et j'aurais voulu qu'ils
qu'ils soient tout aussi présente les
militaires à leurs côtés
ou ce 14 juillet on a l'impression que
le président de la république a tenu à
repenser cette célébration du 14 juillet
ce qu'aujourd'hui justement c'est dans
l'air du temps de repenser peut-être les
célébrations des grandes dates de la
république selon vous je pense que c'est
plus que de les repenser c'est de
renouveler les modes de célébration
cette année
effectivement notamment pour les jeunes
générations qui souvent ne comprennent
pas ce que c'est que le 14 juillet quoi
cela on voit qu est-ce que c'est le 11
novembre puisque c'est louis m toutes
ces grandes dates de l'histoire
grieco
un peu perdu de leur sens donc pour
raviver la flamme de cette mémoire
française comme le font tous les gros
pays les états unis la russie tous les
grandes nations frau un grand travail de
mémoire et du ciné passion
je pense que c'est très important de
renouveler les modes de transmission
donc encore une fois un défilé militaire
c'est très bien mais je pense que de
dire qu'ils adjoint dé ceux des civils
des personnes qui jouent un rôle clé
donc dans la vie de la société ça serait
vraiment une très belle manière de
renouveler en fin d'exercice
et encore une fois je prouve que de voir
aujourd'hui des images différentes avec
ce superbe lampadaires de la ville de
paris dernière le nouveau gouvernement
de la nuit avec jean castex et nouveau
gouvernement
emmanuel macron honnêtement ça
renouvelle l'image et la symbolique des
symboles de la république et je trouve
que ça fait du bien qui va s'exprimer à
la télévision qui va répondre aux
questions des journalistes à l'occasion
justement de cette interview du 14
juillet une interview très attendue par
les français que peut-on attendre
justement voilà de la part du chef de
l'état qui va vouloir relancer la fin de
son quinquennat préparer peut-être les
prochaines présidentielles alors je
pense qu'il ne tombe pas trop en
attendant pourquoi parce que on se met à
deux ans de l'élection présidentielle à
deux en deux ans il est très difficile
voire impossible de faire ou de haut ou
de réaliser toutes les promesses sur
lequel on a été élu il ya trois ans
c'est à dire en 2017 emmanuel macron
faut pas se cacher il a beaucoup déçu
du fait de grandes promesses sont
français il a souvent dans ses discours
portait une idée très hot de la
république française et de son mandat
mais la réalité si peu dans les faits
son quinquennat a été jusqu'à présent un
cas qui n'a un peu à peu horrible avec
les gilets jaunes avec les les grèves
très dures sur les retraites d'affaires
benalla et j'en passe donc effectivement
un cas crésus couronne alias cathy si
violente si dieu on a passé le cap des
trente mille morts c'est probablement
probablement une 40000 à ce que beaucoup
de français son destin son sont morts à
leur domicile et le chiffrage est
difficile à faire
donc avec cette crise terrible le chef
de l'état a voulu prendre l'opportunité
entre guillemets de cette crise pour
tenter de relancer son quinquennat il a
parlé dans son dernier discours d'un
tenter de définir un nouveau chemin et
c'est un petit peu ce qu'il va essayer
des films destinés tout à l'heure dans
l'interview qu'il va nommer dans dans un
peu plus d'une heure de à deux
journalistes pour les devants les devant
les français mais honnêtement encore une
fois à deux ans de la fin de pierre de
quinquennat et quand bien même il aurait
changé de premier ministre
edouard philippe qui a été remplacé par
jean castex il y a maintenant dix jours
je pense que ça va être très très
difficile de changer de cap
sinon de d'ajuster certaines choses mais
honnêtement il ne faut pas s'attendre à
des merveilles
moi je pense plutôt qu'ils maniaient
macron son l'interview de 13 heures le
14 juillet sa première interview du 14
juillet depuis qu'il est président de la
république
ce sera pour moi plus le coût d
le coup d'envoi de sa campagne
électorale sa possible réélection pour
sa candidature en 2022 véritablement des
annonces tonitruantes qui vont changer
la vie des français dans les prochains
mois quels défis attendent le chef de
l'état a là deux ans de la fin de son
mandat aujourd'hui c'est rentrer là je
crois que le premier défi c'est de
calmer l'opinion publique parce que
honnêtement les tensions sociales ont
été extrêmement vit depuis maintenant
plus d'un an depuis novembre 2018 et le
déclenchement de la crise
gilles et jo le 17 novembre 2018 on a eu
sans cesse sans cesse sans cesse des
grèves des manifestations de rue des
violences urbaines
le climat social et et la concorde
civile aboyer défilé a lieu place de la
concorde est ce que les français vivent
dans la concorde aujourd'hui
malheureusement la réponse est non et
c'est vrai que après la crise gilet
jaune après la crise des retraites après
la caisse du corps dhabi russes le géant
multiples avenir petit présent être mis
sur le calmer les choses que nous
puissions terminer son quinquennat au
big man sont correctes en termes de
sécurité en termes de propos violents
ceci a donc ça a commencé la korité
si à la retraite si à la route et à kehl
où quelques mesures que ce soit reprise
par le gouvernement il ya de nouveau des
gains massifs à nouveau une colère
sociale
cette colère ce qu'on sait ce qui classe
vous
honnêtement ça va être très très
difficile d'assumer et le final son
mandat voire même d'envisager d'être
candidat en 2022 donc ça pour moi c'est
la priorité
la deuxième priorité évidemment c'est
une relance économique très très forte
très très ambitieuse que 12 ou annoncé
le premier ministre à la fin du mois
d'août
début septembre et qui doit doter manuel
macumba peut-être dessiner les contours
tout à l'heure dans l'interview
présidentielle c'est de faire une grande
relance économique qui permet de créer
des centaines de milliers d'emplois pour
compenser les nombreux licenciements qui
ont déjà été engagés qui vont continuer
continuer à l'être dans l'est dans les
prochaines semaines à la suite de la
crise de couronnes environ
donc là est un défi il faut que l'état
français
moi je suis un libéral dont puissiez
vous faire confiance aux gens pour faire
tourner l'économie
et lorsqu'il y à une crise terrible et
là c'est ce que nous vivons l'état
stratège
l'état français doit être très présent
en subvenir aux manquements de la
société dont il faut maintenant l'état
soient présents qu'ils prennent des
mesures simples forte direct pour
pouvoir amorcer une relance économique
qui permettra d'éviter le pied parce
qu'encore une fois notamment si la pleut
il ya deux élevages ennuis qui nous
arrive et qui nous tombe dessus
la situation va vraiment vraiment très
difficile à tignes en voilà pour moi
deux des priorités et géant médias un
troisième est à et c'est la dernière qui
a été annoncé notamment par le premier
ministre par jean castex à plusieurs
reprises et il faut le saluer c'est le
réaffirmer les principes d'autorité de
l'état de respect de la lettre et voyez
la surface est content il ya les sociale
et la 2007 public n liberté
étaient représentés moi j'y ajoute la
laïcité
il faut bien que me l'autorité de l'état
le respect de nos entrepôts liste au
respect de la laïcité parce que encore
une fois en termes de valeur il ya eu
beaucoup de manquements ces dernières
mois cette année c'est très important de
les réaffirmer nous sommes en france ne
sommes pas dans un autre pays la france
a des valeurs spécifiques
elle sont universelles bien son
française avant tout il ne voulait rien
pour les prix merci beaucoup à michel
top d'avoir réagi sur notre antenne
rappelle que chaque producteur l'opinion
internationale